hey Gary came in and he told me the TV
guys for some reason you were singing to
cocaine and you were going berserk
found it so I said yeah why you we just
say to cocaine the song babe you do that
in here because I know it can't be
recorded well I should yeah I sit - Gary
I only give Robin the option whether she
wants to play that on the air or not I
know you're sensitive for some reason
about your singing I have to protect
Robin I need her up and peppy there was
something weird going on nobody knows
because nobody else heard it but the TV
guys for some reason was getting we're
getting Robin's microphone because I
think they're like separate feet and I
must be it's separate feed I want to
hear it if you're up for it I'll listen
to it I knew those performances will
never be happening again yeah you better
I never sing it here I don't know why
you are singing I thought it was cute it
wasn't like it's not like your whale and
where is it I want I think it's Gary
page one now I already forgot cocaine
[Music]
it's better this way down to the ground
cocaine
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I like the finger snapping changing the
name of cocaine cocaine cocaine uh not
even true to the words
okay Aina Haina
[Music]